what's up everyone Gordon Ramsay time
this is a must watch it's literally
insane I'll be the judge Abby and her
best friend Rico bought a restaurant
called down City smack in the center of
town okay so he can't be back one day
you got the location I told him that I
was interested in buying down City and
he said I want to own a restaurant too
the Romantic feeling of owning a
restaurant everyone once said spending a
lot of money in restaurants eating and
drinking I figured why not give myself
the money instead
Flawless logic yes we have a full-time
day job and my job is to take care of
everything in this restaurant and I was
putting 100 of my faith in Abby but at
this point let me guess she didn't have
any experience working as a restaurant
uh manager and therefore it all went to
[__]
you is creative and the food is good
coin you see that go bang stop that who
would eat that this burn down these
restaurants immediately what the hell is
that
meatballs no those are for lunch
whatever it looks weird she doesn't want
to admit that she's part of the problem
just give him no let me do it Abby acts
like whatever don't argue Cruella
Deville she's a Cruella Deville Addie is
a complete psycho
can you imagine you're employees talking
about you like that
same
you better see nice things
[Music]
thank you it did look a little mushy
didn't it maybe just Abby's saying it's
great does not make it great that's how
the plate is prepared oh my God they
served that geez Jesus Christ
kind of looks like the one pizza I did
in that one video I'm not gonna lie but
still that's disgusting and now it's
time for a quick break from all the
excitement and Adventure you know when
you're on the go it's important to keep
your energy levels up and that's where G
fuel comes in
foreign
as a gamer and a content creator I
really I rely on G fuel to keep me fuel
and focus throughout the day
whether I'm playing my favorite games
or creating videos do you feel gives me
the energy I need to perform at best
that's why I'm proud to be sponsored by
G field the best gaming energy drink on
the market so if you're looking for a
delicious and healthy way to stay
energized be sure to check out G fuel
now let's get back to the adventure
actually I'm not done sorry thank you
though I couldn't I couldn't have raced
it better myself right now there's a
BOGO sale BOGO are you bogus you buy one
you get one boom one of these flavors
you can get is mine you're welcome this
offer will last up until Valentine's Day
so take advantage of this you get one
for free they got pink drip remastered
it tastes like pink Sardis uh we got
hype sauce raspberry lemonade Sonic
Peaks rings I really like this one I
recommend getting mine and Sonic but
Tiger's blood is also very good the
voice is amazing and we can wrote his
portal fluid it's a great way to try out
some new flavors which is the fun of G
fuel in my opinion there's an infinite
amount and then you always have you know
your fan favorites to rely on
no code required just use the link in
description highly recommend it thank
you g fuel thank you jifu
they hate the chicken pie Arts what
nobody can say anything about the menu
because it's her menu she takes it
personally maybe they're not the right
decisions but they're my decisions
yeah and they're wrong so stop it
they're not the right decision she knows
that at least and I would not listen to
anyone else hello Chef Ramsay how are
you nice to meet you likewise my
pleasure and your first name is Abby
Abby good to see you is Abby gonna find
girl like every girl so far that I
watched on this show
oh my God it's so frenzy I love him and
on a scale of one to ten mark the food
what would you say where are we it's a
10. wow wow wow yeah perfect I'm
starving because the room service next
door was shocking
why why do they have to fool themselves
like it's a 10 it's not a [__] 10.
what do you mean it was shocking there's
a little hotel next hotel we do the real
service from that hotel what was the
problem
honestly yeah that was embarrassing
this pissy grainy soup that was Stone
Cold hold on it gets worse crab cakes
that were stone cold in the center it
was just like this ball of mush
disgusting disgusting disgusting whoa I
was like oh damn he went there he just
really went there that's impossible
that's impossible that the crab you're
telling Mom exaggerating
I think you're one of those customers
that I would fire immediately yeah you
fire customers I have okay that's not
how that works you don't have power like
that oh God what a free people say this
one gets better and I don't I don't I
don't see it but okay I don't need to
search anything because if you're now
telling me that that room service was
you at your best I'm shocking myself
before I start eating let me tell you
that wow
wow good start I don't know what I'm
talking about blah blah blah blah
where would you like me to sit I'm gonna
go right over here excellent describe
the food for me
um comfort food middle of the road
middle of the road when was the last
time somebody sent food back today oh
you did wow wow wow I'm sorry
basically I'm gonna eat and I'm Gonna
Leave unless you start telling me the
truth I I don't know where you're coming
from I really don't know where you're
going absolutely thank you
[Music]
I'm barely started oh my God and they're
already arguing okay crispy rings with
hot sweet pepper sauce yeah I'll go for
some of that okay you don't spell
peppers like that either
it says that it's a party in my mouth
and the um award-winning meatloaf that's
our claim to fame
thanks Josh you're welcome who hands out
these Awards with dishes they say it's
Waterway how does that work huh is this
how you spell peppers in America three
feet because of b-e-p-p yeah there's
three p's in there
oh my God oh my God
he's insane
I mean yeah it is technically three peas
and peppers
he said it was a 10. so I'm in for a
treat
okay what is this thing crispy calamari
calamari yes and
um why is it looking so wet yeah toss it
in everyone loves soggy calamari right
oh God you know Gordon Rams is gonna eat
it like I don't understand I don't
understand
and it's soaking wet all the crispy
batter's just coming off yeah you know
it's not everybody's cup of tea it's not
mine yeah certainly it's not mine either
but however I'm optimistic
okay
I mean look at that that's disgusting
how did the people do it what do you say
about it you spit the calamari back up
[Laughter]
that's hysterical I'm gonna like go at
his throat today
oh that should be interesting please do
yes he's there to help you oh my God I
don't understand people I don't
understand
can't you just be normal it would be
better for everyone and yourself
this is the part in my mouth should be
top plate very hot it looks what the
hell is that where are the nachos I
can't even see them what a mess
oh God how do you dig into how do you
mess up nachos what is that I'm taking
it that was one party either one out of
ten it wasn't a part in my mouth it was
like a funeral in my mouth a feeling
yeah well it kind of does look like
something died
what's mad with that that's gross what's
wrong with it huh I was ready to like
trouble I mean this is the one thing I
like he doesn't like anything maybe this
will be the one what the meatloaf maybe
this will be it this will be it and this
is the core I'm just gonna eat that much
corn get corn out of here bang corn I
had a corn right last video and I do
want to say I I want to apologize to the
corn Community because I didn't
articulate myself properly the problem I
have with corn is that they sneak it
into everything else like here in Japan
they have look at this atrocity what the
[__] saying that's worse that's worse
than pineapple and pizza and pineapple
pizza is not even bite that is
disgusting why would you do this stop
sneaking corn and you go to IKEA I it
hurts me to say this you go to IKEA as
an epic pescetarian I have the veggie
meatballs they're disgusting they put
corn in them I don't want corn in my
meatballs it's like oh it's veggie let's
put some vegetables no they're meatballs
not corn with meatballs whatever idiots
yeah I'm excited thank you you're
welcome
why are they doing this sound effects
this is disgusting
you think sound guy is just like
get out of here
come on you can't miss something
you just can't mess it up that's
disgusting what do we think wow it's not
even hot I'm sorry this sort of lukewarm
solidified chunks of crap that's pretty
much the norm
including me
who is the head chef here we don't
really have one but I guess you don't
have a head chef but I guess I'm the
closest thing the closest what does that
mean talk to me Abby that means that I
fired my other chef and he took over and
I didn't want to give him a title until
he proved to himself that he could
handle the kitchen
so no one's in charge that's great good
stride no guidance there's no standards
no standards there's no consistency so
came up with a
weather for them this is America comfort
food somebody's dreaming here
I did I did I take full responsibility
for the menu you have no cooking
background but you put the menu together
can you be more specific about me look
what did you not like about the meatloaf
oh [__] [__]
bring it on oh come on bring it on
what you mean bring it on Abby has a
conversation with the one person she
believes is always right herself so what
do I do
obviously my 33 years in the business is
like worthless and I have no idea what
the [__] we're doing
okay yeah yes absolutely what were you
thinking I think I'm gonna open up that
hot dog stand down the beach
want some tea or something no
so now you're all telling me that you
don't like the menu
I feel stabbed in the back I guess
you're just hitting me with this now do
you know we're up against if we even
opened our mouth about the menu once
every time we opened our mouths oh [__]
you you don't know anything I feel like
the servers are really like tiptoeing
around it and she can't still can't even
take it it's so ridiculous like they're
just trying to help nice to meet you I'm
Rico Rico no have you got two minutes
sure I'm gonna catch up uh where should
we go yeah let's go there and I bought a
restaurant how's that worked out for you
so far oh horribly if let's close this
tomorrow what are you in for
nine sure what get out of here oh yeah
wow wow I could possibly lose my day job
ready because I'm in the financial field
I'm advising and you know what to do and
financing your properties and things
like that oh my god
um
oh
why and why are you doing this I don't
get it investing things you understand
and know at least and not like oh that
would be nice I would like to own a cow
sorry cow investors
nice the kitchen normally this filthy
last couple of days it's been uh a lot
going on that is a foul with the kitchen
Chef Ramsay goes on the it's part of the
show that I hate so much it's so gross
kitchen should be clean like hospital I
just know I've eaten at so many places
like that you know it too have a look in
there look at the state of what they're
cooking out of have you seen it down is
he gonna shut it down uh what goes where
now you've got a little bag of uh
chicken carcasses on this one here
you've got some raw chicken cooked pork
there this is you with 30 years in the
business chicken doesn't get any
bacteria so it should be funny look at
the cheese or something but what is that
there what is that
[Music]
place is a
is a mess look what is that lamb bones
who's organizing this you haven't got a
head chef Jimmy is my head chef so we
have a head chef before you weren't
ready to confirm he was the head chef
all of a sudden we discover a mess down
here now he's appointed
please
I was talking to Rico has nothing to do
with you
oh okay what do you think I'm doing
you're being a [__] [__]
you're calling me a [__] [__] I am
oh this is gonna be bad precious little
Victory here we go
I'm just saying you're insane
that refrigerator was not like that
before you got here you're in denial
I would never allow that refrigerator
you need therapy
I have never seen him go that hard I
mean good because
her Jesus this is another Amy's kitchen
scene where he can't finish
Ramsey please come back Ramsey please
privacy please
this is uh too serious I'm I'm not gonna
jeopardize with some privacy Mike
silence camera
like that from someone so in denial okay
I'm gonna go for a walk and I'll come
back okay thank you thank you
exactly we can't do another half episode
like English Bakery I gotta just walk
this one how would you feel if someone
just telling you that your life's work
and everything you've dreamed of doing
for your whole life
um is [__] it doesn't matter if you you
can still improve like at any point it's
so ridiculous that they can't take any
criticism tomorrow we need to start
being honest and open so I can start
rebuilding I can't rebuild on BS I agree
I want you to be here I want you to help
me get this restaurant to where I need
it to be what happened she just switched
Chef Ramsay wants to give the staff
something they have been rarely given a
chance to talk freely without getting
fired so that's what we're gonna do I
want each of you to write down
some questions
and direct them to the person you want
and to answer
I wonder who they're going to direct it
to hell day for me don't sign your name
it's Anonymous I knew that if we were
going to do an exercise in talking about
the restaurant I knew that it was all
going to be directed at me thank you
very much
Abby and Jimmy the quality of the food
needs to improve how can we fix it good
question and it all comes down to menu
size with as many items that there are
if you prep for more dishes
the lower the standard
yeah
I always feel weird about that because
in Japan they have
so many things on the menu it's
ridiculous I'm almost like uh they must
just it was frozen yeah since I bought
this restaurant I became a defensive
thing I question and I get upset of the
fact that you're questioning what I'm
doing that's paranoid
we do care about this restaurant you are
our friends so we want to see you
succeed we just gotta talk more instead
of be yelling and screaming can't just
be my show it's not the Abbey show it's
the down City show are you ready to
embrace change
realize that she has to relinquish
control and I think she's going to do it
because I think Abby turning around is
definitely Paramount for this restaurant
to survive good that was productive what
the I'm Gonna Keep it really simple for
tonight's dinner service half the items
are off the menu that chicken didn't
look good it looked like it barely
cooked it at all I would never eat that
disgusting better prepared appetizers
are quickly leaving the kitchen that
sounds kind of like what you should look
like yes
Jesus and when you combine that with a
common under control Abbey at the helm
can you run this to next table please
down City's dinner service is off to a
good start
28. I don't even have a 36 up here I
didn't say 36. one two three come on
guys there's nothing coming out
Jimmy was supposed to be the leader in
the kitchen and calling out tickets give
me a favor get to it oh you're doing
something and they just started crossing
paths no one seems to know what the hell
they were doing back there 29 and 39 yes
or no no I'm still waiting on 28.
no no
his excuse for months has been our menu
is too big so we give them a smaller
menu to do and they still can't turn it
out no I know I know I know it did not
go smoothly but they they they say Jimmy
we were an hour in before
more than two dinners went out I made a
call to a very experienced Chef in my
team to be here first thing tomorrow
morning getting your crew at a
respectable level
to help us all out and it's going to be
a good experience for all of us tomorrow
let's come back day we're relaunching
with a new menu Angus meatloaf
I'm getting hungry look at it
yes get up to speed with those dishes
have a little taste but where's the
calamari Sue that's money the new menu
is the unbelief I had no idea that it
could get this good oh my God I didn't
know food could taste better I had no
clue I just
I've been for years describing this
restaurant as creative comfort food I
had no clue that looks disgusting
[Music]
I don't know if she deserves that
I don't know he looks so creepy I'm
sorry yeah
it's amazing sorry bro let's go let's go
back in the kitchen and then we're gonna
go here a lot of people are really nice
when things are going well Jeff James is
doing the same a locally renowned food
blogger has arrived you know how
important she is
she blocks tomorrow we're ten thousand
potential customers back up I've tried
everything on this menu today so if you
have any questions you feel free to ask
but just when it appears as though it's
going to be smooth sailing it keeps
smooth sailing sorry a slider Jimmy did
you call the calamari for table 30. I
just did Abby and Jimmy listen to me are
having a communication breakdown I need
four soups and one chowder up in the
line please they're not gonna make it oh
here we go again the repeat of last
night just make the calamari just making
dude
he looks like Joey from Friends holy
[__] he does Disney
trouble dip takes six minutes yes yes I
get in the oven Jimmy look at me we're
falling behind we're supposed to work
together
come on guys there's nothing coming out
ten thousand followers
on the table we've got bloggers live
from their table guys
doing her word all
and one day who's getting beat baby
she's live vlogging right now this is a
disaster ah come on guys I need to see
some food up on the slide
listen Jimmy one minute Abigail
waiting for appetizers
she destroyed it no
that sucks what the [__] is this Twitter
please red you better step it up before
she starts her tick tocks everything to
go right with that table that ain't
really screwed listen Jimmy already
vlogging
[Music]
me it's happening which is doing it
again
yes come on keep it going yes oh she
likes it make sure they come together
okay fire that table please yeah Jimmy
37 did you fire I did fire so we got
everything this is a really good with
Abby focused on the task at hand she's
so eloquent with words she must be a
food vlogger or something this is really
good I like this food this salad tastes
nice what is a salad for dinner at a
restaurant go home your food blogger eat
the food and Jimmy in full control of
his kitchen you guys can fire that fish
and chip quality entrees are quickly
heading out to the dining room good job
Joey
food looks amazing
the lamb tastes good and I liked it in
my mouth
oh it's really good and wow
she's better at explaining how was
everything delicious right there
everything was great great all right so
you're gonna tweet that or what hey you
gonna say how good he was I saw you all
the tweets so much for coming in and
we're gonna see you again
don't touch me like that waiters do that
don't ever touch me I ain't gonna tip
you anyway I will if I will how'd you
feel babe I feel beyond belief fantastic
all right all right all right did they
make it uh what was it called down City
in Rhode Island business went up 30
Jimmy's still there I mean Joey the
fridge is organized Yelp reviews were
mostly negative poor quality and scatty
service regulars were not happy with the
changes that that's interesting and they
closed in December 2011. wait so it was
an actual food reviewer why did they say
you had 10 000 followers uh I don't know
they just made it up okay yeah it's
crazy they're always close I know very
little few that actually make it right
all right well that was another great
episode if you enjoyed smash likely back
I'll see you guys in the next one take
care bye